[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
سياده الدول وعدم التدخلة وحسن الجوار وحل
الخلافات بنت حوار وتواصل المملكه وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد ان الاتفاق مع
ايران شمال احترام سياده الدول وحسن
الجوار وحل الخلافه
في تسليح كييف وسط توقع امريكي بهجوم
اوكراني مضاد في مايو المقبل
الحكومه الفرنسيه تلجا لماده دستوريه
لتمرير تعديلات التقاعد بدون موافقه
البرلمان
بريطانيا تحضر تيك توك على الاجهزه
الحكوميه وواشنطن تخير الشركه المالكه
ببيع المنصه او الحظر كليا
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه اكد
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ان المملكه تدعم حل الخلافات عبر
الحوار ومن هذا المنطلق توصلت الى اتفاقيه
مع ايران بعد جلسات في مسقط بغداد وبكيم
معربا في كلمته خلال افتتاح المجلس
الوزاري لدول التعاون الاسلامي عن تطلعه
في ان تنعكس الاتفاقيه ايجابا على المنطقه
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤمن باهميه
ما يجمعنا من روابط الدين والجوار وتبسط
يدها دوما للحوار يحل الخلافات بالطرق
السلميه
ومن هذا المنطلق اجرت لاكثر من عامين عده
جولات للحوار على الشقاء ايران في كل من
بغداد واسقط ثم مؤخرا في بكين وقد تكلت
هذه المباحثات بالاتفاق على اداه الاعاده
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه من البلدين على اساس
احترام مبادئ ومقاصد ميثاق المتحده ومنظمه
التعاون الاسلامي وفي طليعه احترام سياده
الدول وعدم التدخلة وحسن الجوار وحل
الخلافات حوار ونتطلع الى ان يعزز هذا
الاتفاق من امنه واستقرار منطقه الخليج
العربي ويدعم مسيره العمل الاسلاميه
المشترك
وفيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه على حق الفلسطينيين في
دوله مستقله على حدود عام 67 مدينا في
الوقت نفسه انتهاكات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بحق الشعب الفلسطيني تؤكد
المملكه موقفها الداعم للاسراع في ايجاد
الحل عالد وشامل للقضيه الفلسطينيه وفق
قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره السلام
العربيه
واقامه دوله فلسطين مستقله على حدود عام
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه والمملكه كانت ولا
زالت تدعم الشعب الفلسطيني لاستعاده حقوقه
المشروعه
والمجتمع الدولي للقيام بدوره في وضع حد
الانتهاكات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني وتقويض فرص احياء
عمليه السلام
هذا وشدد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على دعم
المملكه المتواصل للسلامه في اليمن ولكل
المجهودات الداعيه لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل
دائم
ان المملكه تجدد دعمها للسلام في اليمن
ولجهود المبعوث الامني الى اليمن الراميه
الى التوصل لوقف كامل ودائم لاطلاق النار
وبدا العمليه السياسيه بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين وتؤكد على دعم مجلس
القياده الرئاسي اليمني لتمكينه من تنفيذ
سياسات ومبادرات فعاله من شانها تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار بالجمهوريه اليمنيه
وانهاء الازمه
الى ذلك اكد مصدر سعودي للعربيه ان
الاتفاقيه الامنيه واتفاقيه التعاون
متعدده المجالات التي تم الاتفاق على
تفعيلها مع ايران توضح اهميه ما سيترتب
على تبادل الثقه والاحترام من فرص ايجابيه
تنعكس لفائده الشعبين وجميع شعوب المنطقه
كما شدد على ان الالتزام باحترام السياده
وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه وحل
الخلافات بالطرق السلميه يشمل جميع الدول
العربيه والاسلاميه وعبر عن امله في ان
ينعكس هذا ايجابا على كل الملفات والازمات
في المنطقه
الى ذلك افادت صحيفه
بموافقه ايران على وقف تسليح الحوثيين في
اطار الاتفاق على استئناف العلاقات مع
السعوديه كما اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى ان
نهج ايران حيال الصراع في اليمن سيكون
اختبارا حقيقيا لنواياها بعد عوده
العلاقات مع الرياض وان هذه الاتفاقيه
ستعطي دفعه للتوصل الى صفقه لانهاء النزاع
في اليمن في وقت قريب
مستشار الالماني او لا انه من المهم جدا
تامين ذخائر بسرعه لاوكرانيا من اجل
التصدي للغزو الروسي داعيا الشركاء
الاوروبيين لايجاد تدابير جديده بهذا
الخصوص
سنستمر مع شركائنا الاوروبيين في ضمان
حصول اوكرانيا على اسلحه ومعدات للصمود
والدفاع عن نفسها من المهم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره اللازمه بسرعه في المجلس
الاوروبي وجمبا الى جنب مع شركائنا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي سنتفق على المزيد من
الاجراءات لتحقيق امدادات افضل وبشكل
مستمر ونحن مستعدون لفتح مشاريع المشتريات
في المانيا للدول الاعضاء ايضا
وفي مقابل ذلك نشرت صحيفه بوليتيكو
الامريكيه نقلا عن مصادر ان اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن تتوقع قيام اوكرانيا
بهجوم مضاد في مايو المقبل لاستعاده
اراضيها كما اوضحت الصحيفه الامريكيه ان
شركاء اوكرانيا الامريكيين والاوروبيين
يقومون بتزويد بكميات ضخمه من الذخيره
والقذائف مصادر الصحيفه اشارت ايضا الى ان
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد سيكون من خلال
احتمالين اثنين الاول من خلال الهجوم
جنوبا عبر نهر خرسون الى شبه جزيره القرم
اما الاحتمال الاخر فسيكون من خلال شن
هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه بحر ازوف
بهدف قطع الممر المؤدي الى شبه جزيره
القرم
ميدانيا افاد رئيس السلطه المواليه لروسيا
في دونتسكلين بعدم وجود اي مؤشرات على
انسحاب قريب للقوات الاوكرانيه في بخموت
مشيرا الى ان المعارك في المدينه الواقعه
شرق اوكرانيا ما تزال صعبه ومعقده للغايه
كما اشار الى ان الجيش الروسي بدا هجوما
موسعا من محاور عده على مدينه
للسيطره عليها
وفي جديد ازمه المسيره الامريكيه قال
الكرملين ان الجيش الروسي سيعمل على
انتشال حطام المسيره من قاع البحر الاسود
اذا اعتبر ذلك ضروريا للامن القومي من جهه
اخرى اعرب الكريم عن اسفه لمساعي السويد
وفنلندا للانضمام الى حلف الناتو مشددا
على ان روسيا لم ولن تشكل تهديدا للبلدين
هذا فيما نشرت القوات الامريكيه مقطعا
مصورا لعمليه اسقاط مسيرتها من قبل القوات
الروسيه فوق البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه اذهب الى سباس ينضم
اليه من هناك استاذ العلوم السياسيه
الدكتور عمار قناه دكتور عمار اهلا وسهلا
بك صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه تتوقع هجوما
اوكرانيا كبيرا مضادا في مايو المقبل
لاستعاده الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا هل
يمكن للاخذ بهذا الكلام ام لا هو مجرد
دعايه لرفع المعنويات لا اكثر ولا اقل
تحياتي سيدي الكريم من الملاحظه ان في
المراحل الاخيره ان قيادات الاركان يعني
هي قد انتقلت الى الصحافه الامريكيه فلا
زلنا يعني نستمع الى هجوم هجوم اوكراني
هجوم مضاد اقتحامات تحرير مدن وكلها هذا
ياتي ضمن يعني المربعات الاعلاميه لا اكثر
ولا اقل المساله هنا يعني اكبر من ذلك وهو
يعني مرتبط بالخلل والارتباك في المنظومه
الغربيه من حيث التسليح اوكرانيا وايضا
التباينات والتناقضات في الداخل الاوروبي
والغربي بشكل بشكل عام كما قلنا يعني منذ
بدايه الازمه المشهد الذي امامنا هو ليس
فقط يعني مشهدا عسكريا بل هي معادله
من خلالها تحاول جميع الاقطاب توظيف يعني
التوظيف السياسي التوظيف العسكري وايضا
يعني مساله ما يتعلق خصوصا في ضخمه والذي
اعتقد انه قد ضخمت يعني وتضخم لغايه الان
اعلاميا بناء على الاخطاء الاستراتيجيه
التي قدرت توكلت منذ البدايه فجعل الرمزيه
يعني لي هذه يعني المدينه هو ما اوقعهم
اليوم يعني في هذا المازر فلا نستمع الا
عن هجومات وهجومات مضاده والسؤال الاكبر
يعني باي اسلحه اليوم يعني يجري الحديث
يعني كيف ستتم هذه الامور لاحقا طيب بس
دكتور عمار هذا لن يمنعني من سؤالك لماذا
لم تستطع القوات الروسيه حتى الساعه برغم
التفوق الجوي والقوه الناريه الهائله
ومجموعات فاجنر من حسم معركه باخمون
سؤال مهم جدا استاذي الكريم وهنا ارى ان
روسيا هي ليست يعني في عجله من امرها
لمفهوم الحسم العسكري وذلك لا ننسى
الارتباط يعني الارتباط الوثيق ما بين
المعادله العسكريه والمعادله السياسيه فمن
هنا يعني يمكن البدء نرى ان روسيا من خلال
العسكريه الجديده انها يعني في محاوله
اعطاء مهل يعني هو فرص للنخبه السياسيه في
اوكرانيا وايضا يعني للغرب فهي تفتح
المجال حتى لخروج القوات يعني الاوكرانيه
وهي تحاصرها يعني من كل الجهات المساله
ليست لها يعني علاقه كما اراها يعني
بمساله قدرات عسكريه او يعني ضعف عسكري ام
قوه عسكريه وايضا يعني فيما يتعلق في هذه
المنطقه هي مناطه فقط يعني بفصيل او قوات
فاجنر فقط يعني ياتيها الدعم الناري من
الجيش الروسي الجيش الروسي لغايه الان هو
لم يتقدم الى منطقه وهنا ايضا يعني لا
يمكن الحديث بان يعني كلمه السر في المشهد
العسكري هي فقط طباخ [__] محاور اخرى
تدور فيها وتحتدم
المعاركنا الايمان وفي فيزا وغيرها لكن
يعني اهميه طباخ مت هنا ناهيك عن الرمزيه
ثانيا انها يعني الخط الدفاع الاساسي
ولذلك يعني ما بعد باقي ستكون اكثر سرعه
باعتقاد الدكتور عمار انت انت تعرف يعني
في يعني ما يتداول في الاعلام تحديدا
الاعلام الغربي
تحليلات مفادها ان ما يحول دون سيطره
الروس على على هي الخلافات المتصاعده بين
فاجنر وبين القوات النظاميه الروسيه هل
فعلا شقت الخلافات واسعه جدا بين الطرفين
ام لا هذا مجرد توزيع ادوار
سيدي الكريم يعني نستمع كل يوم تقريبا
لتصريحات يعني مؤسسه
لا اعتقد انها مساله يعني خلاف ولا يمكن
يعني ان تصل الى هذه المرحله وذلك ان يعني
قوات هي جزء او فصيل يعني رديف للجيش
الروسي ولا يعتبر يعني جزءا اساسيا من
العمليه العسكريه هو فصيل مناظمه
منطق لا اكثر ولا اقل لكن يعني عاد
حتى يعني العسكريه من خلال يعني ملفات عده
والوعود بالملفات الدبابات والطائرات
وغيره وهم يدعوهم في الصحافه الى التوجه
خلق يعني ماده اعلاميه جديده والهدف منها
تصديرها يعني للمنظومه المجتمعيه الغربيه
بان هناك مقاومه ولذلك يجب ان ندعم
اوكرانيا دكتور عمار بالنسبه الى ازمه
المسيره الامريكيه التي اسقطت فوق البحر
الاسود هل تعتقد ان هذه الازمه اقفلت يعني
هذا حدها ام لا سيكون لديها فصول ستتواصل
في الايام المقبله
بهذه التحركات
يعني اعتقد انها بامتياز يعني هي حركه او
عمليه استفزازيه كان لها ثلاثه يعني اهداف
اساسيه اولا عسكريه اختبار القدرات الجويه
الدفاعيه في منطقه البحر الاسود لروسيا
ثانيا سياسيا
في امكانيه يعني التوجه لتوسيع رقعه
الصراع الدائر في اوكرانيا وثالثا اعلاميا
وهو مرتبط يعني بلفت النظر عما يجري في
الداخل الامريكي من ازمه يعني ماليه
لتوجيه الراي العام الامريكي والدولي الى
مسائل اهم لكن لا اعتقد واجزم ممكن القول
يعني اجزم بانه لن تكون هناك تط يعني في
هذا في هذا المشهد او خاصه يعني هذه
العمليه لانه
لا روسيا ولا الولايات المتحده اليوم هي
معنيه بالتوصل الى الصدام المباشر يعني
عسكريا فلذلك اعتقد ان المساله قد انتهت
والدليل على ذلك يعني من خلال التصريحات
الاولى كانت روسيه
امريكيه انه لم يتم استخدام يعني اطلاق
نيران وايضا الاتصال الهاتف ما بين وزير
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لنظيره الروسي هذا التاكيد يعني واضح
بانها مساله يعني وقد يعني يعني
تكون هناك تطورات من استاذ العلوم
السياسيه دكتور عمار قناه شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
هذا ونقل موقع انسايدر عن تقارير روسيه
محليه ان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تخطط
لتجديد 400 الف من المتطوعين سيتعاقدون
معهم لثلاث سنوات مع نهايه هذا العام
400 الف جندي روسي اضافي الى جبهات القتال
نهايه هذا العام تعبئه جديده تخطط لها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه منذ الاول من المقبل
وحمله تجنيد قوامها متطوعون تسعى الى
تعزيز القوه البشريه في الجيش الروسي
بنسبه 50% وفقا لتقارير محليه
التقارير افادت بان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ابلغت رؤساء الاقاليم بقرار التعبئه وبعدد
المجندين الذين يتعين عليهم تجهيزهم مع
نهايه العام
كما شوهد مسؤولون عسكريون في المناطق
القريبه من الحدود مع اوكرانيا يوزعون
مذكرات استدعاء على السكان طالبوهم بتحديث
بياناتهم بمكاتب التجنيد وفقا لبي بي بي
سي روسيا
وسائل اعلام روسيه اخرى ذكرت ان الجيش
الروسي ينتظر من المجندين الجدد ان يكونوا
ذوي قدره على تشغيل المدرعات والمدفعيه
خاصه بعد تقارير السابقه اشارت الى ان
الذين تلقوا تدريبا محدودا قتلوا بشكل
جماعي وفي حاله تنفيذ هذه التعبئه تكون
الاخيره تناقضت مع تصريح سابق لوزير
الدفاع الروسي فبراير الماضي نف فيه اي
خطط لتعبئه ثانيه
يذكر ان موسكو في سبتمبر الماضي اعلنت عن
تعبئه جزئيه ل 300 الف من جنود الاحتياط
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
تظاهرات جديده في اسرائيل ضد تغيير النظام
القضائي والحكومه ترفض تعديلات الرئيس على
القانون
اهلا بكم من جديد بدا قاضي محكمه جنائيه
في العاصمه الباكستانيه نظر في تعهد قدامه
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان لوقف العمل
بمذكره الاعتقال ضده فيما يعرف بقضيه
الهدايا والمثول امامها في جلسه يوم السبت
المقبل وسلم محامي رئيس الوزراء السابق
التعهد الخطي لعمران خان للمحكمه للبتي
فيه
الى ذلك قدم فريق قانوني لرئيس وزراء
فاكستان السابق طلبا امام محكمه لاهور
العليا لوقف العمل بتنفيذ مذكره الاعتقال
الصادره ضد عمران خان بين ان قاضي المحكمه
اجل النظر في القضيه الى يوم غد الجمعه
وكان محيط مقر اقامه خان قد شهد مواجهات
بين انصاره والشرطه التي قدمت اربعه
بلاغات ضد عمران خان وانصاره لتعطيل عمل
الشرطه
ما عمل لهون لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني
الذي يتابع هذه الاوضاع عن كثب عبد الرحمن
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد من عندك هل
الامور هادئه وسلكت طريقها نحو الحل ام لا
النار ما زالت تحت الرماد
نعم الوضع هنا هناك حاله من الترقب الحذر
في صفوف انصار رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خان لاسيما بعد قرار قاضي
المحكمه الجنائيه في استرابات رفض التعهد
الذي قدمه رئيس الوزراء والالتماس الذي
قدمه فريقه القانوني بالغاء مذكره
الاعتقال بحق ضد عمران خان وطالبه بالمصول
وضروره الوصول امام المحكمه يوم السبت
المقبل على هذا او في نفس السياق قاضي
المحكمه العليا في مدينه لاهور اصدر بيانا
او حكما تفصيليا بشان جلسه اليوم سمح
او او
مدد من المهله التي
طالب بها حزب الانصاب بزعامه عمران خان
بوقف الاجراءات اعتقاله حتى
الجمعه اذا يوم غد الجمعه سيكون يوما
حاسما اما ان يقوم عمران خان بتسليم نفسه
طواعيه لقوات الامن الباكستانيه او للشرطه
او
المثول شخصيا امام قاضي المحكمه الجنائيه
لتجنب الاعتقال كما ذكر ذلك قاضي المحكمه
اليوم هذه القضيه هي ضمن عدد من القضايا
التي
يواجهها رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
عمران خان قال انه المشكله ليس في المثول
امام المحكمه قال ان هناك تهديدات جديه
على حياته الى سيما ان المحكمه الجنائيه
في شمال سبق وان تعرضت لعدد من الهجمات
الانتحاريه خلال الاعوام السابقه وادى ذلك
الى مقتل وقتل العشرات من بينهم قضاه
ومحامون ايضا اشار الى ان هناك نحو اكثر
من 80 قضيه وبلاغا يواجهها واصفا
الاتهامات له بالمسيسه والسوريه
وانها لا تتبع الاجراءات القانونيه
المعهوده ويتهم الحكومه بانها تقف وراء
هذه
القضايا من اجل حرمانه من الترشح او خوض
وفي كلام في كلام بس في كلام لو سمحت لي
في كلام في الصحف بعض الصحف الباكستانيه
انه بوادر صفقه تلوح في الافق وفي بعض
الاطراف تعمل عليها وقف ملاحقه عمران خان
تماما مقابل وقف جميع تجمعاته وحملاته
الاعلاميه ضد الحكومه وضد السلطات في
باكستان هل
هنالك يعني هل لهذا الكلام ارضيه
ممكن الاخذ به ام لا
نعم اليوم حقيقه كان هناك تصريحات اعتبرها
مراقبون بانها موقف يتجه الى الليونه
لرئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان قال بانه
مستعد للحوار مع كافه الاطراف وايجاد
وتقديم تنازلات من اجل مصلحه البلاد
والحفاظ على ما وصفها الديمقراطيه في
البلاد ربما
يكون هناك محاولات لذلك لكن هناك اجراءات
قضائيه يجب على عمران خان ان يمتثل لها
ومن ذلك ومن ضمن هذه الاجراءات الامتثال
امام مختلف المحاكم والقضايا التي تطالبه
بالمجهول امامها اما
الاحكام فهذا ما
سيقرره
القضاء الباكستاني لكن عمران كان ايضا حذر
في نفس الوقت من انصاره قد يخرجون عن
السيطره في حال طالما وصفه ان استمرار
القوات الامن بقمع المتظاهرين الاجواء لا
تزال هنا اعتياديه الحركه اعتياديه هناك
ربما يعني هذا ايضا يمنع الشرطه من القيام
باي عمل ربما
قد نشهد خلال يوم الغد فيما لو لم يمتثل
عمران خان بقرار القاضي على كل سنكون معك
يوم غد لمعرفه كيف ستؤول الامور من لهون
مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن على كل هذه المتابعه
مثل حاكم مصرف لبنان المركزي رياض سلامي
امام القضاء اليوم على خلفيه اتهامات
بغسيل الاموال وجرائم اختلاس
ومع وصول سلامي الى جلسه التحقيق فرضت
الشرطه اللبنانيه اجراءات امنيه مشدده
داخل قصر العدل اثناء التحقيق مع حاكم
مصرف لبنان علما بان التحقيقات تشارك فيها
خمس دول اوروبيه على الاقل وبقائمه تضم
100 سؤال على ثلاثه ايام وقد تولى قاضي
التحقيق الاول في بيروت شربل ابو سمره
طرحه هذه الاسئله من دون مشاركه من القضاه
الاوروبيين
اذهب الى بيروت مباشره لمزيد من المتابعه
تنضم الي من هناك مراسله العربيه غنوايتين
من امام قصر العدل غنوا اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
ما رشح من جلسات استجواب حاكم المصري في
المركزي رياض سلامه وما هو مصير رياض
سلامي يعني هل ستسطر بحقه اي استنابه
قضائيه ام لا هذا مستبعد تماما
طالب يعني كما كان متوقع انتهت هذه الجلسه
عند الساعه الرابعه بالتوقيت المحلي
لمدينه بيروت ولكن لم نتمكن بعد من معرفه
ما اذا كان سيكون هناك جلسات لاحقه خاصه
وان هناك
مئه سؤال يعني المفروض هذه الاسئله موجهه
لرياض سلامه من اجل معرفه بعض الاجابات
حول مواضيع اتهمه فيها القضاء او الوفد
الفرنسي متعلقه بالفساد وبتبيض الاموال
حتى الان لن نتمكن من التوصل الى القاضي
يبدو انه لا يزال هناك اجتماع رغم مغادره
رياض سلامه لي يقصر العدل لمعرفه ما اذا
كان سيكون هناك جلسات لاحقه ولكن من
المتوقع ان يكون هناك جلسات لاحقا نظرا
لكثره الاسئله
كما علمنا بان كان هناك استراحات متعدده
خلال هذه الجلسه بحسب يعني مصادر كانت
موجوده في الداخل سليمه بدا مرتاح لم
يصطحب اي من محاميه محاميه اللب ان كان
معه محاميها الفرنسي فقط اضافه يعني خاصه
وان الوفد هو وفد اوروبي ما الذي سيحدث
لرياض سلامه بعد هذه الجلسه هذه الجلسات
هو استدعى اليها كشاهد
يعني فقط للاستماع اليه وليس
يعني كمشتبه به او كمتهم حتى الان ولكن من
المفترض انه بعد انتهاء هذه الجلسات وبعد
حصول القضاء الوفد القضائي الاوروبيه على
المستندات الذي اللازمه ان تتخذ هذه
الملفات الى الى الاوروبي في الخارج يتم
دراستها وعليه يا اما ان يثبت تورط
السلامه بهذه القضايا التي شكك فيها
القضاء الاوروبي ممكن ان تصدر بحقه ااا
توقيف عبر الانتربول ممكن ان يكون هناك
وضع يد على ممتلكاته ولكن هذا يعود
لما لما ستتوصل اليه هذه التحقيقات القضاء
اللبناني لا يحق له توقيف سلام يعني حتى
وان كان هناك قرار بتوقيفه من قبل القضاء
الاوروبي لا يحق للقضاء اللبناني توقيفه
فقط يكون هناك امكانيه توقيف عبر
عبر الانترنت
لفتني اليوم يعني بعض الكلام في الصحف
اللبنانيه انه لو لم يكن هناك ضمانات
لرياض سلامي بعدم توقيفه لما كان حضار هذه
الجلسه بمعنى ان مظله الحمايه على رياض
سلامه ما زالت قائمه هل يمكن للاخر بهذا
الكلام غنوه وانت تتابعون هذا هذه الامور
عن كثب اكثر منا
نحن نعلم يعني قضايا رياض سلامه
لاكثر من مره طالبت بتوقيفه وطالبت
باستدعائه وهو لم يصل امام القاضي
اللبنانيه الفضاء اللبناني هذه الضمانات
هي ليست من القضاء الاوروبي لانه بطبيعه
الحال لا يمكن توقيفه بهذه القضيه الان
ولكن كان هناك مخاوف من ان يكون هناك
خطوات قد تتخذها القاضيه غاده عون وايضا
هناك ضمانات يعني قد طالب بضمانات امنيه
رياضه يعتبر اليوم بان هناك تخوف امني على
حياته لا يمكن ان يتنقل بحريه لذلك يفضل
ان تستكمل هذه الجلسات على عجل الا يكون
هناك عدد كبير منها خاصه طالب انه يملك
يعني
اضافه الى السياسات الماليه التي يعتبر
مسؤول عنها هو يملك عدد كبير من الاسرار
للمسؤولين السياسيين لذلك هناك يعني يعتبر
ان هناك خوف امني على حياته اخر اخبار
الانهيار المضطر في سعر صرف الليره كم بلغ
سعر صرف الليره الان مقابل الدولار وهل
الناس في لبنان يربطون بين استدعاء سلامي
وبين هذا الانهيار المريء في الليره
باختصار
طالب يعني انا حتى اخر يعني اخر مره نظرت
الهي الى سعر صرف الدولار كان الصباح هذا
اليوم وبعدها كان لدينا يوم طويل مع رياض
سلامه كان مئه واربعه الاف لا اعلم لانه
هناك الدولار يتغير اليوم في لبنان بين
ساعه واخرى لا اعلم ان كان قد تعدى تعدى
يعني هذا المبلغ وهو بالفعل يعني مبلغ
كبير يعني قبل يومين فقط كان مئه الف هناك
ارتفاع الان نتحدث عن ارتفاع باكثر يعني
4000 ليره في بينما كان في السابق بمائه
كبيره او 200 ليره طبعا يعني هذا هذا يعني
بان الانهيار هو انهيار سريع جدا بسعر
الصرف مجرد اصلا الوصول الى 100,000 يعني
الوصول الى سته ارقام لي سعر الدولار
الواحد هذا ايضا رقم كبير جدا بالطبع يعني
هناك امور عده اوصلت الدولار الى هذه الى
هذه الحال ولكن من ابرز الاسباب هي
السياسات التي والت عليمات التي اتخذها
حاكم مصرف لبنان من بيروت مراسله العربيه
غنوه يتيم شكرا جزيلا لك غنوه على هذه
المتابعه
تشهد اسرائيل اليوم تعبئه جديده احتجاجا
على مشروع تغيير النظام القضائي قناه
تقديم الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق مشروع
تسويه عرضته الحكومه على الفور ويحافظ
مشروع هيرتزوك على الطرح الحكومي بحد قدره
المحكمه العليا على الغاء قوانين اساسيه
لكنه يقترح تعديلات على النقاط المثيره
للجدل في قانون النظام القضائي
ويعتبر معارضون مشروع تغيير النظام
القضائي انه يمنح السياسيين مزيدا من
السلطه على حساب القضاء
قال زعيم الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي ان المجلس سيصوت هذا
الاسبوع على الغاء التفويضه للحرب السابقه
في العراق قبل ايام من الذكرى العشرين
لغزو العراق وقال شمر ان الوضع على الارض
تغير كثيرا منذ فتره طويله ويجب ان تتغير
القوانين الموجوده في الكتب ايضا
وهذه احدث محاوله لاعاده تاكيد دور
الكونجرس في اتخاذ قرار بشان ارسال القوات
في مهام القتاليه وقد وافقت لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ على مشروع قانون
لالغاء التفويض باستخدام القوه العسكريه
في حربي 1991 و2003 ضد العراق
عشرون عاما مرت على الغزو الامريكي للعراق
ولكن حتى يومنا هذا ما تزال القوات
الامريكيه تحتفظ بوجود صغير لكنه ثابت في
المنطقه في ذروه حرب العراق عام 2007 كان
يتمركز 170 الف جندي امريكي في العراق وقد
انخفض العدد اليوم الى ما يقرب من 2500
وسط تساؤلات حول عدم تمكن الولايات
المتحده من انهاء وجودها العسكري تماما
في عام 2011 سحبت الولايات المتحده قواتها
لكنها عادت بعد ثلاث سنوات في عام 2014
لمواجهه داعش ولم تغادر بشكل كامل منذ ذلك
الحين
ووفقا لمسؤولين امريكيين فان هذا الوجود
المستمر هو لضمان منع عوده محتمله للتنظيم
المتطرف اضافه الى الحد من نفوذ ايران
السياسي والعسكري في العراق والذي تنام
وبقوه منذ غزوه قبل عشرين عاما وتقول
التقارير ان القوات الامريكيه في العراق
تجعل من الصعب تهريب الاسلحه الايرانيه
عبر ايران وسوريا الى لبنان كما انها
تساعد في توفير الدعم اللوجستي لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه التي يقودها الاكراد في
القتال ضد تنظيم داعش
نشد الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
تهدد بايت دانس الصينيه المالكه لتيك توك
اما بيع المنصه او الحظر في الولايات
المتحده
اهلا بكم من جديد اختار رئيس الفرنسيه
بحسب مصادر قريبه من الحكومه هذا الاجراء
يرتكز على بند دستوري يسمح للحكومه بتمرير
القانون من دون عرضه على التصويت في
البرلمان
مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي كان قد اعلن المصادقه
بالاغلبيه على نص التسويه لاصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي يقضي برفع سن التقاعد من 62
الى 64 عاما وذلك في المرحله ما قبل
الاخيره والتي كان يجب ان تليها مرحله طرح
النص على الجمعيه الوطنيه في فرنسا وقد
علت صيحات استهجام مع بدء جلسه الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه بعد قرار تمرير اصلاح
التقاعد دون تصويت
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
باريس الان مراسل العربيه فادي دهوك فادي
اهلا وسهلا بك اولا الصوره من حيث انت كيف
تبدو والقانون اقرر بدون التصويت عليه في
البرلمان يعني الحكومه رفعت قفاز التحدي
وماضيه الامور تتجه الى اين وهل ستكون
الكلمه للشارع الان
ستكون للشارع وهذا خير دليل المتظاهرون
يقفون خلف وصلوا الى مدخل مجلس النواب
الفرنسي ايضا هناك حشد امني كثيف جدا
وهناك اليات للشرطه
والجندرمه الفرنسيه
تقريبا في كل منطقه هنا حول مجلس النواب
الجلسه الان مستمره هي تم تعليقها لبضع
دقائق بسبب
هتافات ضد مشروع القانون او ضد نيه رئيس
مايكرون استخدام الماده 49.3 لتمرير
المشروع من دون التصويت في البرلمان كان
هناك طبعا صعوبه لان يتمكن من ايجاد
الاصوات اللازمه لكي يمر هذا القانون
خصوصا في جهه النواب من حزب اليمين
الدغولي التقليدي عبر عدد كبير منها او من
هؤلاء النواب عن عدم استعدادهم للتصويت
وقالوا انهم سيرفضون التصويت نعم لمشروع
القانون هذا الان هناك تظاهرات بدات تخرج
في معظم الساحات الفرنسيه هناك ايضا عدد
كبير من الطلاب الذين غادروا من جامعه
السربو وهم يتجهون الان الى امام مجلس
النواب حيث تدور الجلسه وحراك هذا الطلاب
الذي يدخل على خط التحركات والاحتجاجات قد
يغير الكثير وتاريخيا فرنسا الحركه
الطلابيه غيرت الكثير في الحياه السياسيه
الفرنسيه خيار الرئيس ماكرون باستخدام هذه
الماده ايضا كان له محاذير كثيره
يعني استخدام الرئيس ماكرون للماده
49.3 كان مفاجئا للجميع ام لا متوقعا
استخدامه لهذه الماده كان متوقعا لكن عدد
كبير من وزرائه قالوا انه ان المساله لم
تحسم بعد
وكانوا ياملون لا يصلوا الى هذه المرحله
لكن بما انه لم يتامل النصاب اللازم لحصول
التصويت في مجلس النواب لذلك هو قرر
استخدامها والقرار اتخذ قبل ساعات قليله
جدا من بدايه جلسه مجلس النواب من خلال
اجتماعه مع وزراء حكومته ومع رئيسه
الوزراء اليزابيث اجتمعوا في قصر الاليزي
وتم اتخاذ القرار
باتخاذ او بتمرير هذا القانون عبر استخدام
الماده 49.3 طبعا هذا سيغامر بشعبيه
الرئيس بشعبيه الحكومه ايضا وهناك بدات
تحركات من قبل المعارضه الان زعيمه اقصى
اليمين مارين لوبين اعلنت انها ستطرح
مذكره لحجب الثقه عن الحكومه وايضا
الحزب الاشتراكي قال ان مذكره لحجب الثقه
ايضا سيطرحها في الساعات القليله المقبله
يعني ونشاهد هذه المشاهد هل مازال هنالك
اي وسيله للطعن بهذا المشروع ام لا الامور
انتهت على الاقل من وجهه نظر الحكومه
الفرنسيه
بانتظار ما سيكون عليه رد فعل الشارع
الفرنسي
من وجهه نظر الحكومه الامور انتهت هذا
القانون سيتم اقراره عبر الماده 49.3 لكن
الكلمه الان سوف تكون للشارع التقيته احد
اعضاء النقابات وقال انهم يحضروني تحركات
ضخمه وهذه التحركات ستشمل اضرابات كبيره
جدا سيتنضم قطاعات اكثر
للاضرابات ايضا ستكون هناك حركه طلابيه
كبيره جدا وهم ينسقون هذا الامر مع الطلاب
بالاضافه الى حركه السترات الصفر ستكون
سيكون هذا الاسبوع اسبوعا حاسما في فرنسا
وحاشدا بالتظاهرات والاضرابات ايضا
قالوا لنا انهم سيقومون بمحاوله عرقله
اقتصاد البلاد وعمل نوع من
ان يشلوا الاقتصاد لكي يؤثر على الحكومه
ويجبرونها
قليل هتافات لهؤلاء المتظاهرين الذين
ترونهم كانوا يطالبون
وكانوا يقولون حتى لو لم يرد ماكرون
وجودنا هنا نحن سنتواجد في الشارع
مع هذه المشاهد نختم معك فادي دهوك مراسل
العربيه من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المتابعه
اعلنت بريطانيا عن حظر تطبيق تيك توك على
الاجهزه الحكوميه وذلك خوفا من كيفيه
استخدام البيانات الحساسه على المنصه
الاداره الامريكيه من جهتها وضعت بايت
دانس الصينيه الشركه الام لتيك توك بين
شقي الراحه فاما بيع التطبيق الواسع
الانتشار او مواجهته الحظر الكامل في
امريكا وجاء هذا الانذار النهائي لتيك توك
من قبل الوكاله الامريكيه المكلفه بتقييم
المخاطر التي تمثلها الاستثمارات الاجنبيه
على الامن القومي بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه وول
ستريت جورنال
المدير التنفيذي لتيك توك
ان عمليه بيع تيك توك لن تحل مخاوف الامن
القومي الامريكي رئيس التنفيذي اكد ان سحب
الشركه من اصحابها الصينيين لن توفر حمايه
اكثر من الخطه التي وضعها تيك توك والتي
تتضمن الاستعانه بشريك امريكي في الشركه
الاداره الامريكيه كانت قد عبرت عن
مخاوفها من محتوى التطبيق على الامن
القومي
وطالبت بتغيير ملكيه الشركه او حظر
التطبيق في الولايات المتحده
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
شددت من جهتها انه على الولايات المتحده
وقفه قمع الشركات الاجنبيه مضيفه ان
واشنطن لم تقدم حتى الان ادله على ان تيك
توك يهدد الامن القومي
لقد اكدنا دائما على ان قضيه امن البيانات
لا تكون اداه لبعض البلدان لتعميم مفهوم
الامن القومي واساءه استخدام السلطه
الوطنيه وقمع الشركات بشكل غير معقول
الجانب الامريكي فشل في تقديم ادله على ان
تطبيق تيك توك يهدد الامن القومي للولايات
المتحده ويجب على الجانب الامريكي التوقف
عن نشر معلومات خاطئه حول قضيه امن
البيانات والتوقف ايضا عن قمع الشركات
وتوفير بيئه اعمال عادله وغير تميزيه
للشركات من جميع البلدان للاستثمار في
الولايات المتحده
انشطه الزلزاليه ما تزال متواصله فبعد
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
زلزال عنيف يضرب نيوزيلندا بقوه 7.1 درجه
على مقياس ريختر ليزيد من حده القلق بخصوص
تداعيات الهزات الارضيه على قشره الارض
حيث كشفت دراسه علميه ان الزلازل المستمره
تسببت في اتساع صدع موجود في افريقيا
اخبار الكوارث الطبيعيه لا تتوقف افريقيا
القاره قد تنشطر الى نصفين هذا وفق تقرير
اعده باحثون بريطانيون ونشر في دوريه جيو
فيسكا جورنال لكن لا داعي للفزع فهذا
الامر قد يستغرق بين خمسه الى عشره ملايين
سنه والسبب هو الزلازل التي ادت الى
تصدعات في قشره الارض اخرها الزلزال القوي
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا وخلف نحو
50 الف قتيل هذا الزلزال وصل التداعياته
الى القاره السمراء زلزال تركيا وسوريا
وقع بين ثلاثه صفائح تيكتونيه وتسبب في
تحرك صفيحه الاناضول ثلاثه امتار غربا
وادى ايضا الى تحرك الصفيحه الافريقيه
وساهم في اتساع ما يعرف بصدع الشرق
افريقيا الذي اصبح اكثر نشاطا مع تزايد
الحركه مستمره داخل القشره الارضيه الصدع
يبلغ طوله سته وخمسين كيلو مترا او 56
كيلومترا وظهر في الصحاري الاثيوبيه في
عام 2018
يمتد نشطه في شرق افريقيا اسفل كل من
اثيوبيا وكينيا وتنزانيا حيث تشير دراسات
الى ان تحركات الصفائح قد بدات من منطقه
عفار شمال اثيوبيا وانتشرت جنوبا نحو
زيمبابوي وبمعدل يتراوح بين السنتيمترين
ونصف الى خمسه سنتيمترات سنويا هذا
الامتداد يقع فوق نقطه تقاطع ثلاث صفائح
التكتونيه تتقشر ببطء شديد وتنزلق بعيدا
عن بعضها البعض وهي عمليه جيولوجيه معقده
يقول العلماء بانها ستقسم القاره السمراء
الى قسمين ما يحدث في الصدع يمثل تماما
الحركه التي كونت البحر الاحمر ولكن بمعدل
اكثر بطئا وفقا ما نشر في دوريه جيوفسكا
جورنال وخلص او وخلص العلماء القائمون على
الدراسه الى ان تشكيل محيط جديد في
افريقيا يمكن ان يكون وهو امر مرجح وبعدها
سيتقدم قاع البحر على طول الصدى هنا ستصبح
القره الافريقيه اصغر حجما وستشكل جزيره
كبيره في المحيط الهندي تضم اجزاء من
اثيوبيا والصومال وكذا القرن الافريقي
الخامسه انتهت اطيب التحيات والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]